في الجنه يا رافع راسي
صرخته غضب وهتافات تحيي المقاومه واخرى
تطالب بالانتقام من الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هذه الاجواء رافقت موكبه تشييع شهيدي حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي محمد السعدي ونعيم
الزبيدي في ازقه وشوارع مخيم جنين
حركه الجهاد اكدت انها ماضيه في مواصله
المقاومه لا يمكن لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
ان تسلم للاحتلال وانت تثق بهذا الاحتلال
هذه طبيعه الاحتلال يريها للشعب الفلسطيني
وليل العالم كل يوم انه طبيعته اجراميه لا
يمكن التعايش معه لا يمكن لمن يقتل الشعب
الفلسطيني ان نتفاوض معه
والى مقبره الشهداء بمخيم جنين توجه موكب
المشيعين الذي شاركت فيه معظم الفصائل
الفلسطينيه
واعتبرت الفصائل والحكومه الفلسطينيه ان
الحكومتين الاسرائيليتين سابقه والحاليه
وجهان لعمله واحده
وتهديفان الى مواصله حربهما ضد
الفلسطينيين هنا في مقبره الشهداء بمخيم
جنين
غريا جثمان الشهيدين السعدي والزبيدي لين
ضمنا الى من سبقوهما من شهداء المخيم
وامام هذا المشهد يقول الفلسطينيين انهم
مستمرون في التصدي للاحتلال وعملياته
العسكريه ضد المخيم ومقاومته
ففي فجر الخميس بدات قوته لاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عمليه عسكريه سريعه في قريه
وادي برقين وحي الهدف على اطراف مخيم جنين
الغربي
القوات الخاصه تسددت الى عمق الحي
ونشره القناصه في بعض البنايات وحاصرت
منزلا بهدف اعتقال مشتبه فيه مطلوب
لاسرائيل
لقوات الاحتلال ودارت اشتباكات المسلحه
بين الجانبين اسفرت عن استشهاد السعدي
والزبيدي واعتقاله فلسطينيين خلال
العمليات العسكريه سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره
جنين فلسطين